hello there reject Nation I'm here doing
my obligatory Keanu Reeves impression that
everyone else is going to do leave a like
that would be very much appreciated guys
we got ourselves an official trailer for
John Wick chapter four love the frick out
of this franchise man I am so excited to see
this I love the teaser trailer they released
for this during Comic Con now we got a two and
a half minute one here learning exciting things
about this film man so let's just get into
it and see what's going on in this trailer
saying goodbyes saying hello
I hear Donnie Yen's voice you think your
wife can hear you no no don't wipe on
Maybe I'm Wrong
flashback maybe not goodbye I got
at least one more movie Donnie Yen
the new day is Dawning new ideas no wounds
New Management we've known each other
Danville Skarsgard something huh who is this
challenge him to single combat win a lose it's a
way out I don't sit at the table who
your family does please pray for me
above oh it's time to get married
or buried I'm going to need a gun
wow what the table will honor its
word dogs we will have your freedom
under the old laws Clancy Brown failure to
meet at Sunrise will result in execution
Last Words Winston just have fun out there
oh damn yes
yes it's amazing way up the stairs I want you
to find your peace but a good death only comes
after a good life it feels so introspective
hiroyoki Sonata and Donnie and fighting man you
and I left a good life behind a long time ago my
friend oh it's gonna be such an epic fight let's
man that looks awesome looks so awesome uh let's
talk about it alrighty well I thought this was an
excellent trailer because the first teaser trailer
that we got at a Comic-Con really leaned into the
action and it was short brief but it was you
know the thing you you kind of wanted the John
Wick films that hardcore action to me even though
I don't think the first one has the best action
it's still my purse I like I like all of them
but it's my personal favorite out of the three
films that came prior to this one just because of
the mood and the tone and uh just how like Primal
and personal of a Revenge Thriller felt and this
one kind of it's not a Revenge movie this this
one seems like that that Quest revengeance always
lives on with John Wick however this had something
that felt a lot more dark a lot more harrowing
and feels very existential in some ways it was
like it's like a funeral March so they kept
alluding to John Wick might die in this movie
now if they did not announce that there's a John
Wick 5 also coming I might be sold on it maybe
he'll die in part five I think it'd be a bold
move of the franchise for him to go out dying
regardless what this movie will be exploring at
least from what the trailers are alluding to those
existential qualities you know when he's sitting
down at the beginning thinking about his wife
wondering about you know is there an afterlife
where she does it exist can can she hear him
the pondering with Donnie Yen's uh Kane character
one of the fun motifs of the John Wick franchise
is meeting a new character who you find out has
like some type of fun history with John Wick that
there's some background with them even the way
they're capturing it currently at least in the
marketing would Donnie Yan and Keanu Reeves that
even looks personal I did hear a while ago that
that would probably be like the heart and soul of
this movie their former friendship that they had
I love that dude we're going to be getting this
dynamic between them that actually feels personal
it feels meaningful versus just like a fun wink
and a fun nod and some of the more fun clips that
we normally get with a new character who has a
a past witch John Wick but then as the trailer
even progresses more you know the Lawrence
fishburn's Bowery King is even talking about
how you you got to be the best dressed for your
wedding or for a funeral you know like whatever
the hell he says there there's so many hints at
the possibility of him dying and I and I keep
wondering too he's like John Wick probably has a
Death Wish of his own and he probably wonders if
he deserves to live or not I think this will be
the first John Wick sequel to not just pick up
where immediately where the last one left off
there's probably going to be a time Jump which
would make sense at the end of John Wick chapter
three dude was jacked and jacked up like badly he
was he was really he was really messed up even
for my suspension disbelief I was like can you
can he can he really how could he still operate so
this gotta be a little bit of a time Jump here but
the plot that they have uh unfolding with oh this
like Hunger Games like story getting involved in
a game this time in order to to get his freedom
I think we're actually really going to explore
the high table this time around this seems to
have a quality of what it must be like to be a
warrior being an assassin exploration of that I
guess what I'm trying to get boil it down to in
the most basic form is it feels character study
again about the guy or at least thematically of a
study of them while bringing us the action scenes
because yeah the the action I'm sure is going to
be top-notch when you have a stage like this set
up of of a Last Man Standing game there's only
going to be one person left everyone else is going
to die you know the body count is going to be high
it's a fight for survival and I think that's
the main thing that brings it back to feeling
like the first one for me brings it back to that
Primal feeling I don't know how things will get
resolved with Winston after everything that went
down I'm sure John Wick wants to kill him maybe
there'll be some type of understanding they end
up coming towards who knows who knows who knows
but come on there's so many fun things to look
forward to Bill Skarsgard is a phenomenal actor
right like he's more than Pennywise it's done
a lot of work work and and to see him step his
toes in here I'm so excited to see what he does
I wonder if he gets any particular likely great
action scenes which would be like so different for
the guy I think I can't recall a movie where I've
seen Bill Skarsgard do a bunch of action maybe
it's out there and I just can't recall it right
now he wasn't Deadpool too you know of course
Scott Atkins getting to be in here as well you
know you're going to get some brilliant action
scenes there the thing I'm most excited for is
Donnie and hiroyoki Sonata who is a phenomenal
actor by the way always brings such great pathos
to his roles is it in his contract that he has
to be wielding a sword because he has another
sword fight scene in here and every movie I see
this guy in or even a show he's always wielding a
sword I mean I'm not complaining I feel like it's
you gotta do it I was even randomly rewatched the
rush hour franchise at my own time totally forgot
that he was the main bad guy in rush hour 3. and
even in there he has a sword fight scene at the
end I'm like damn for decades this guy's just
been doing sword fights I don't know the backer on
him but you know it's just kind of uh humorous to
me that that always seems to be the case so yeah
and even this is not going to be the last one of
the friend franchise it feels like a movie that is
also encapsulating all the movies that came prior
looks like they're tying it all in you know they
bring up the John Wick family you see them from
chapter three in here got Bowery King bringing up
the vibes from the first movie maybe in the fifth
one is when you get like the Cinematic Universe
Collision of all the John Wick characters like
Halle Berry might return in that one or or Ruby
Rose even you know like get get all the people
who survived from the previous films to come
back in one more film which would actually be
a cool John Wick five but with this one it looks
dark it looks meaningful looks personal looks
introspective looks mournful it's my cup of tea
man what did you guys think about this John Wick 4
trailer leave your thoughts down below subscribe
leave a like all right guys catch you all soon
foreign